hello YouTube artificial intelligence
BOTS please don't demonetized me this
video has nothing to do with brexit and
there's absolutely nothing offensive
about the word cockney today i want to
examine a unique and extremely creative
form of English slang called cockney
rhyming slang cockneys are traditionally
defined as people living within earshot
of the bow bells of the Saint Marie
LeBeau Church in the East End of London
but the term cockney has come to refer
to working-class Londoners in various
parts of the city and surrounding areas
cockney rhyming slang was first
mentioned in a book published in 1859
and had probably begun to be used in the
1840s so what the heck is it okay I'll
give you the most basic and cliche
example of cockney rhyming slang I went
up the afwan pace the phrase apples and
pears is a substitute for the word
stairs so you take a word that rhymes
with the original word and then use it
to create a pair of related words that
pair of words now represents the
original word in this case stairs here's
the most interesting part the second
word of the pair the one that rhymes
with the original word is usually left
out as in I went up the apples but how
are you supposed to know what it means
well originally this kind of slang was
not meant to be understood by everybody
it was created by Street merchants and
criminals in order to prevent other
people from understanding what they were
talking about but it soon became a
colorful form of expression rather than
just covert communication let's look at
some more classic examples we'll start
with the word house a rhyming word is
Mouse a complementary word is cat so cat
Mouse means house I went inside the cat
and mass and at the f1 pace it's
theoretically possible to shorten both
of the rhymes and say the sentence I
went inside the cat and up the a force
but it would probably be said the long
way in order to be less confusing here's
another example using an animal word the
original word is phone phone rhymes with
bone what animals are normally
associated with bones dogs of course so
dog and bone means phone so there's this
sentence process the dog meaning pass me
the phone
in cockney speech sometimes the plural
pronoun us can be used with the singular
meaning
instead of me here's one more sort of
household object freezer a rhyming pair
is Monalisa notice here that in my North
American accent Lisa and freezer don't
rhyme but the cockney dialect and most
dialects of England are non-rhotic
meaning that the are consonants are only
pronounced before vowels freezer in
North American English is freezer in
cockney English and Lisa rhymes with
freezer I got some hands and feet from
the Mona the sentence seems a bit
strange you've got hands and feet in
your freezer well no actually that's
another piece of rhyming slang meaning
meat but speaking of hands and feet here
we have a pair of Germans a German what
exactly German bands and bands rhymes
with hands German bands refers to
travelling musicians from Germany who
used to perform in British cities in the
nineteenth century another one here we
have a pair of plates plates of what
plates of meat which of course rhymes
with feet and here's your loaf loaf of
bread of course bread rhymes with head
and here's your boat short for boat race
race rhymes with face and here are your
minces mince pies which rhymes with eyes
and this one can be heard all the time
and here's your North your North and
South in other words your mouth there
are often a number of different rhymes
with the same meaning here we have
bottle of beers or King Lear's or Lords
and peers
of course these all rhyme with ears so
we could refer to your ears as your
bottles or your kings or your Lords
there are lots of cockney rhymes that
include cultural or literary references
there's a cup and Geoffrey on the table
Geoffrey comes from Geoffrey Chaucer in
Chaucer rhymes with saucer Geoffrey
Chaucer is called the father of English
literature and is the author of The
Canterbury Tales let me pull Samoa in
the Hansel Hansel comes from Hansel and
Gretel which is more like Hansel and
Gretel in cockney pronunciation and
Gretel rhymes with kettle Hansel and
Gretel is a German nursery rhyme
published by the Brothers Grimm in 1812
so here we should note that the T in
water as well as the T and Gretel is
generally pronounced as
glottal stop in cockney English so while
in some British accents it would be
water in cockney it's whoa and rather
than Gretel its Gretel and we heard the
same thing before in the word bottle
which is pronounced bottle other rhymes
reference celebrities and influential
people tell me the babe babe comes from
Babe Ruth the legendary American
baseball player
Ruth rhymes with truth so this means
tell me the truth let's go for a couple
of Whitney's Britney comes from Britney
Spears the American pop singer Spears
rhymes with beers this means let's go
for a couple of beers from that last one
you can see that new cockney rhyming
slang is being created all the time
there are classic rhymes and there are
modern rhymes but whether these modern
rhymes are legitimate cockney rhyming
slang or not is up for debate some of
them are widely considered mockney
rather than cockney mock meaning
imitation or fake cockney rhyming slang
is not only used by genuine cockneys
these days it has found its way into the
speech of people all over the UK and
even further afield and some people
imitate a cockney accent and throw in
cockney rhyming slang even though
they're not from London and not
working-class if we take a look at
Britney Spears on cockney rhyming slang
Co UK we see that opinions are divided
over whether this one is classic modern
or mockney I would think that this one
should be modern or mockney since a
classic would be something like apples
and pears that has been used for decades
I guess if you liked the rhyme you'd
probably classify it as modern if you
don't like it and think it's corny and
inauthentic you'd probably say it's
mockney so what do I think is it modern
or mockney
well I'm British so I ain't got a skooby
skooby skooby do clue ain't is a
negative copula and auxiliary verb that
originated in cockney English ain't got
means haven't got or don't have there
are a lot of cockney rhyming slang
expressions that are rude naughty and
downright dirty we're going to avoid the
rated-r ones but the next couple are
kind of pg-13 that bloke over there is a
merchant merchant banker wanker
last night I got a bit Brahms and Fermi
heiress Brahms and Liszt pissed as in
pissed drunk heiress Aristotle bottle
bottling glass us to finish this video
I'd like you to practice the pattern of
cockney rhyming slang by creating your
own cockney rhyme to all the genuine
cockneys out there I'm sorry for the
sacrilege I know that I'm encouraging
large-scale mockney but it's all for the
purpose of understanding the pattern of
genuine cockney rhyming slang so
remember the pattern take a word like
socks find a rhyming word blocks add
another word to make a pair Lego blocks
then take away the rhyming word Lego
then in the comments write a sentence
that gives some context so we can guess
the word my feet were cold so I put on
me Legos
be sure to follow Lange focus on
Facebook Twitter and Instagram and once
again thank you to all of my patreon
supporters especially these ones who are
my top tier patreon supporters special
thanks to them thank you for watching
and have a nice day
[Music]
you